no you do not get priority because you
chose to have kids okay if you have not
already seen that video and followed the
comment thread please go do this right
now so I used to work at this place and
I had moved across state to work at this
place and I worked with this woman let's
call her Karen who had two kids and I
also just want to mention that until
this incident me and her had gotten
along perfectly fine so that year I knew
that I wanted to go home for like the
week or so of Christmas break I wanted
to see my family I was homesick and I
put in to leave for that week like
months in advance literally months and I
had also send my boss like multiple
emails throughout the months just to
remind him that this was happening so
it's the week before the break and I am
so excited I've already packed like my
family's expecting me I have friends who
are expecting me I'm expecting me so the
week before my boss calls me into his
office let's call him Bob and he's like
hey Evie listen like I know you were
planning to take off for vacation but I
talked to Karen and she decided that she
really wants to take her kids to Disney
World over the break and I was like and
he was like I was just really hoping
that you could find it in your heart to
like let her take your week so she can
spend some time with her children and he
also has kids so he was like totally on
her side about it and I was like you
know what Bob I did what you said I
searched my heart and it turns out that
there is nothing in my heart that's
going to make me willing to give her my
week no but for real though I was like
Bob I literally put in for this like
months in advance like I have people my
family's expecting me and he's like I
know I know I know he was like I was
just really hoping that you would just
be willing to give it to her so she
could spend time with her kids I was
like did she even put in for this and
he's like no she literally talked to me
about it this morning 48 hours after
some things went in the work environment
in the nine-to-five environment that it
boggles the mind
remember
I was working for a phone company right
selling phones in the store and it's
crazy how we would get two 15-minute
breaks
and lunch right but the people that
could that were smoking could go out and
smoke
every time there was like a break I let
me go for a break and imagine was like
yeah you know what I did
I bought a pack of smoke and I said let
me go smoke
but you don't smoke and I was like I do
now
just to have the same privilege as the
[__] it's weird
that you're like you're gonna they have
extra breaks like I can't go on break
but they got extra break because they
smoke it's like if I was working in an
environment be like yo I'm gonna go on a
cocaine break it's a drug at the end of
the day and you're gonna think you allow
them to take a break and I can't that's
weird there's some stuff like that where
oh kids before anything else it's like
nah man she goes through the process
that's the reason why we have those
rules so that things like that could be
fair but no Karen over here can just
yeah but you shouldn't have done it
before that what do you want me to do so
what do you want me to do give it to you
I don't have to give it to you whenever
your employer tells you I hope that you
would find it in your heart that means
you ain't got to do [__] I hope when you
find it in your heart to let both of us
go on break yeah yeah this is such a
matter of the heart sir your job can
take a little bit of financial hit you
better find it in your heart find it in
your heart the both of us on vacation
yeah
yay you better not guilt Trooper okay
because she already did she already did
the minute you say find it in your heart
that makes you a not good person if you
don't find it in your heart means you
don't have you didn't find it in your
heart or you didn't know how to you
didn't have a heart to find it anyway
listen yeah but she got kids so there's
a process to do follow that that's the
and those rules are there in place so
that everybody in the workplace is equal
you doing that makes the one with kids
not equal to the rest that's the Andy
Chad who decided that your children are
more important than my family
you know who decided but you know what
forget my family maybe I just want to
take a trip because I feel like going
somewhere
what do I got to do with my flights lose
that money what do I got to do with that
every day but even if I can let's I can
move it what if I don't want to what if
I you know what if I want this what if I
plan my whole last few months in order
to get this time off and I've been
looking forward to it I gotta put up my
own happiness for yours no hey hey you
talking about oh oh we'll think about
the kids [__] I'm a kid
but I'm the kid that works in your
company you're a grown ass man you know
like I'm a kid my mama doesn't give a
[__]
my mama doesn't give a [__] if I'm a
grown ass man if I pay my taxes if I got
my vaccine if I were to I'm a kid to her
I'm a [__] and I'm about and I'm
about to say to my mom I can't come
because carrying a kid my mom is gonna
be like [__] that [__] I'm also the kids
of someone I'm the kid of someone else
so find it in your heart for this kid to
go see so so this kid can spend some
time with his family how about that you
know it's funny it's like people with
kids ought to say you'll never
understand you'll never say yeah don't
good luck [__] best of luck with
whatever I don't understand that's your
problem bro I just did I just did
understand
my mama want to spend some time with her
kids too I do understand I get that So
the faster what it's like to be like
your mom shut the [__] up I don't
understand it you don't have kids you
don't understand it you don't understand
we could play that all day and you don't
understand what it is like what it is to
be uh the kid of my mom okay but I'm
going
I'm going what are you saying are you
saying you got to choose I haven't said
[__] my mom watches this Channel watch
yourself
I'm going
that's all that's all I'm saying that
that's the thing you're also funny what
you live in the same city as your mom
not anymore but yeah yeah you still
going I'm so
I don't I don't understand
I don't care she lived next door I'm
going Christmas my mom is not even here
she's in Florida okay what now
but even if she was here
I'm going and I'm spending a whole week
there 48 hours
I was like listen I'm sorry like I'm the
sucks that she's not gonna get to take
her kids to Disney World but like I'm
not I'm not giving her my week I'm sorry
and he was like big like Dad
disappointed like he was like oh okay
well you're gonna have to go out there
and you're gonna have to tell kids
that's your job brother no no that's her
job that's your job you're bummed out
because you don't want to do it you
don't want to do your job yeah if you're
a good manager don't abdicate your
[__] responsibility
oh that's when you want to delegate is
that what it is it's all put in a notice
literally this morning no no no no no no
this morning you're gonna have to tell
her uh and you want her no you gotta
tell her she put a notice if she wants
to go with her kitchen Disneyland so bad
why don't you plan that [__] house
if it's so important to her why did she
only do that this morning a week out no
no and you're gonna make me do your job
if that she can't take her kids to
Disney World you're gonna have to tell
her and I was like okay
I walked right out of his office walked
right up to her desk and I was like
listen Karen I just talked to Bob and I
know he said that you wanted to take
your kids and for me to give you my week
but like I'm sorry like I'm just not
gonna do that I was like I'm sure you
can take your kids to Disney World at
another time that's like scheduled and
she got so mad you guys like the
entitlement was Unreal she was like you
don't understand I need to spend time
with my children I have children like
they need to see their mother and I was
like Karen like I hear you I was like
but I haven't seen my family in a year
like you live with your kids like you
see them every day she was like you have
no idea what it's like like you have no
idea how I feel right now when she
actually started to cry
yeah I don't care what nobody says I'm
not gonna lie but women cry just start
laughing
yeah I'm sorry that that [__] is so
manipulative to me and so childish I I
stopped feeling sympathy for women's
Tears like 95 of the time I see somebody
cry for something privilege I'm like go
ahead [__] it's entertainment for me
use that [__] as lube later when I took
one out yeah absolutely your tears my
memories
whenever I whenever I see that then I do
four notes
you know every soap opera I have that
now
[Music]
nah bro that [__] I don't see too many
women use that [__] manipulatively and I
say women because that is a womanly
thing to do I never seen a dance a man
try to cry okay and I will say this even
in this instance she's being incredibly
manipulative right now she knows she
didn't go wrong she knows logically but
she don't care because of whatever she
got that's your problem nah that's on
you I don't know what you got going on
your life but no that's just no and the
worst thing is you're a grown ass woman
with kids out here losing it because you
didn't put any fourth that's your
problem don't be trying to make someone
else feel guilty while you you you
should cry because you haven't handled
your [__] not because she said that's
your problem
and the [__] up thing is that whenever
that girl that's talking whenever she's
gonna have her uh her report on her how
she's doing her work
her her boss probably gonna be like well
you don't really play well with the
other yeah you're not a good player
you're not a team you're not a team
player
get the [__] out of here yo it's not
just the tears it's like you know this
mission
able she gonna carry this resentment
over this is something that's gonna last
in the word Plex because she didn't do
her due diligence now I gotta suffer at
work yeah no bro I got no sympathy for
those tears cry more I hope you cry when
you get home too stupid she just kept
saying like you have no idea what it's
like to have children you have no idea
what it's like to love like this and I
was like I don't know I mean like I love
my parents like a lot so she was like
you won't know unless you experience it
and I was like you know what Karen
that's probably true but I am about to
experience this vacation see you in a
week
good for you absolutely yay and she
deserves it too
yeah I made it
we need to normalize that no a shout
outs to her that's probably true but I'm
about to experience
[Music]
Oh my days that's bars you crying cause
I won't give you my time with my family
so you can spend time with yours that's
why you crying I'm a bad person because
I don't want to give you time with my
family so you can spend time with yours
that's why you crying no sir good
you can finish this
all right uh I'm gonna tell you some
parents out there right uh sometimes
your go-to phrase whenever we talk about
[__] like that and talk about your kids
and then like that it's like you can't
talk you ain't got keys you can't talk
you ain't got kids well guess what all
right I am not a fight fighter but if I
see a fire I know it's a [__]
fire you understand what I'm saying so
yeah there's some things like that that
I can understand even if I haven't
experienced them well you'll never shut
the [__] up I'm not that stupid okay so
yeah it's not it's not gonna be maybe to
your level granted but I can still
understand how it feels and you don't
have a special need you don't have a
special pass you're not special you're a
parent and that's pretty much it so calm
the [__] down with that [__] you're not
special either because you got kids plan
your [__] and do your thing is there
anything else I guess not comment
subscribe and you know go check the
merch pace